[Música]
el parlamento ruso aprobó una ley que le
otorga poderes al kremlin para reprimir
el periodismo independiente tras la
decisión varios medios internacionales
anunciaron el cc de su operación en
suelo ruso
Twitter y Facebook quedaron
completamente bloqueados dentro del
territorio ruso el regulador de
comunicaciones de ese país señaló que la
restricción se debe a que ambas redes
sociales eran portales de difusión de
noticias falsas
y en Ucrania cada vez son más los
menores que son Víctimas de la guerra
decenas de niños están ingresando a
hospitales y otros se enfrentan al
Calvario que supone huir de su nación
en francés 24 estamos de vuelta con las
noticias que marcan la jornada soy
Valentina Torres Sánchez y es un gusto
acompañarlos iniciamos en Rusia tras
bloquear los servicios de facebook y
Twitter el parlamento ruso aprobó una
ley que otorga a Moscú poderes más
fuertes para reprimir el periodismo
independiente con la nueva Norma que
tiene penas de hasta 15 años de prisión
varios medios internacionales anunciaron
el cese de sus labores en suelo ruso los
detalles con Juan Pablo lucumí
destacados medios internacionales dejan
de informar en Rusia después de bloquear
el funcionamiento de las redes sociales
facebook y Twitter el parlamento ruso
arremetió contra quienes difundan lo que
se pueda considerar por las autoridades
rusas como información falsa en relación
con sus operaciones en Ucrania
esta Norma obligará a soportar un
castigo muy grave para aquellos que
mintieron e hicieron declaraciones que
desacreditan a nuestras fuerzas armadas
quiero que todo el mundo lo entienda la
nueva legislación puede castigar con
multas de hasta 15 años de prisión y
espera establecer más controles
estrictos sobre los contenidos que el
público nacional consume sobre la
invasión en Ucrania medios
internacionales como la bbc la voz de
América Franz radio Liberty blomber news
dolcebelle CNN y la agencia de noticias
F ya suspendieron su labor informativa
en suelo ruso
Esperamos que nuestro personal que vive
y trabaja en Rusia vuelvan al aire en el
futuro próximo pero nos estamos tomando
una pausa porque se trata de una
legislación completamente nueva y no
sabemos en verdad Cuál será el nivel o
la aplicación de la Norma y no queremos
descubrirlo a las malas esta misma
semana la Unión Europea decidió vetar la
difusión de los medios rusos sputnik y
today en los países del bloque algo que
generó opiniones divididas en los
europeos según un reporte de Human
richwatch emitido el año pasado Rusia ha
estado cerrando la libertad de prensa en
los últimos años y la organización
reporteros Sin fronteras dice que los
periodistas son tildados de agentes
extranjeros y sufren de ambiguas leyes
selectivas que los llevan a las cárceles
previamente conversamos con Wilson Vega
periodista especializado en tecnología y
actual editor del portal web ABC
diario.com que nos contó que tanto
afecta a la población el bloqueo de
redes como Twitter y Facebook en
realidad es un gesto significativo si
bien la presencia e influencia de redes
como Facebook no es la misma en Rusia de
lo que podría ser en países de este lado
del mundo pero no deja de ser importante
por por el principio de control del
discurso es muy claro que para músculo
importante es tener control de una
narrativa que en sus medios es una sola
en donde no caben voces disidentes pero
que a través de recursos como Facebook o
como Twitter pues se escuchan muchas
otras voces disonantes y lo que quiere
es tratar de mantener el control sin
embargo es la primera vez que nosotros
vemos una situación relativamente grande
con un gobierno como el ruso haciendo
presión para que las redes normalmente
lo que vemos es que esa presión para que
bajen contenidos en este caso está
haciendo presión para que mantenga
arriba y no oculte contenidos que les
son favorables a la visión del mundo
el presidente de Rusia ha Vladimir Putin
es la cara visible de la invasión a
Ucrania pero está rodeado de un círculo
interno Leal que toma decisiones tras
bastidores en el siguiente informe vemos
quienes tienen el poder de influir en el
jefe del kremlin
estos seis hombres que forman parte del
círculo de confianza de Vladimir Putin
son quizás los únicos capaces de influir
en el presidente ruso una de las
personas que habla al oído de Putin es
el ministro de defensa de Rusia sergey
Go su confidente desde hace muchos años
este hombre de 66 años carece de
experiencia militar pero se le atribuye
la toma de crimea en 2014 y se le ha
relacionado con varios envenenamientos
de agentes alguien con una verdadera
experiencia militar es Valery gerassimov
el jefe de Estado Mayor de las fuerzas
armadas de Rusia quien también es lea la
Putin un sistema en el que Putin es el
jefe de la mafia y todo el mundo le teme
todo el mundo es sus súbditos nadie
quiere tomar una posición independiente
alguien que lo sabe muy bien es director
de inteligencia exterior de Rusia
sergeiner skin es reacio a oponerse a
Putin en un intenso intercambio Putin lo
presionó para saber si apoyaba la
decisión de reconocer como estados
independientes a dos regiones
separatistas de Ucrania apoyadas por el
kremlin
apoya su apoyas habla directamente
apoyo la propuesta dígalo entonces
Gracias puedes sentarse pero es Nicola y
patricef el secretario del Consejo de
Seguridad considerado el hombre con más
influencia sobre el presidente ruso ha
sido descrito como el Halcón de Halcones
patrullero está a favor de la guerra y
es el menos indicado para frenar a Putin
arcadi rottenberg podría ser la voz de
la razón el multimillonario es amigo de
la infancia de Putin ha sido golpeado
por las sanciones de occidente pero los
lazos Entre él y el presidente ruso se
han debilitado
ha intentado utilizar la distancia como
proyección de poder pero también crea
algunas medidas de salud o incluso de
seguridad Tú tienes alguien que sabe
cómo se produce en este tipo de intentos
de asesinato ha estado involucrado en
algunos de ellos
es por eso que Putin tiene a su lado a
Víctor soloto quien dirige la guardia
Nacional de Rusia una fuerza de 3000
hombres cuyo objetivo es proteger a
Vladimir Putin a toda costa
el presidente
ucranianonsky informó que conversó con
el fundador de tesla y creador del
sistema starlink y long musk el
mandatario anunció que Moss enviará más
terminales satelitales de internet
durante la próxima semana que permitirán
acceso a su servicio en ciudades donde
la infraestructura de comunicaciones ha
sido atacada
entre las víctimas de la guerra en
Ucrania están los niños su presencia
aumenta cada vez más en los hospitales
mientras que otros se enfrentan al
Calvario del Éxodo desde los hospitales
ucranianos los médicos dan la voz de
alarma niños heridos a veces muertos y a
menudo traumatizados como los de Natalia
ha refugiados en el metro de kiev El
soldado dijo corre rápido daba mucho
miedo
el más pequeño de mis hijos corría y
gritaba más rápido más rápido nos están
disparando no vamos a sobrevivir y
vinimos aquí ahora mi hijo tiene miedo
de salir yo era todo el tiempo mamá de
noche no mi hijo mayor grito en la noche
mamá protégete
muchos de estos niños se ven obligados a
abandonar Ucrania en condiciones
difíciles varios días en la carretera y
horas de caminata antes de poder llegar
a un lugar seguro en el camino los
equipos de unicef intentan brindar lo
necesario a las familias que se dirigen
al exilio lo primero es el tratamiento
de los traumas de los niños es
imprescindible hacerlo inmediatamente
tenemos psicólogos que están
acostumbrados a este tipo de situaciones
y que crean condiciones de protección
hay zonas de juego para los niños y
también hay distribuciones de agua y
comida y pañales porque los pañales son
necesarios imagínense tres días de viaje
en coche sin pañales y con bebés se
necesitan toallitas y Cuantos más niños
tengamos en la carretera
Tendremos que cuidar este aspecto tan
importante
había Polonia Hungría Eslovaquia y
República Checa son países donde estas
jóvenes Víctimas de la guerra intentan
encontrar Refugio se calcula que más de
la mitad del millón y medio de
ucranianos en el exilio serían niños
unicef hizo un llamado a las donaciones
del jueves de 400 millones de euros
cambiamos de tema y finalizamos en
México donde se registraron violentos
enfrentamientos entre hinchadas de los
equipos de fútbol de Querétaro y Atlas
protección civil reportó una veintena de
heridos y hasta el momento se desconoce
la cifra de fallecidos los aficionados
invadieron la cancha del estadio la
Corregidora en Querétaro donde la
batalla campal se extendió hasta las
graderías y las afueras de las afueras
del campo deportivo el partido tuvo que
ser suspendido y los jugadores se vieron
forzados a refugiarse en los vestuarios
Atlas Fútbol Club lamenta y reprueba los
eventos suscitados en el estadio la
Corregidora el fútbol debe ser un Aliado
para promover valores y diversión para
toda la familia solicitamos a las
autoridades pertinentes a la Liga BBVA
MX y a la fmf investigar a fondo y
llegar hasta las últimas consecuencias
determinando responsabilidades a quienes
resulten involucrados y se aplique toda
la fuerza de la ley es todo por el
momento los invitamos a visitar nuestra
página web France 24.com para ampliar
todas las noticias y repetir este y
otros programas continúen con nosotros
que hay más en francés 24
[Música]